I've tried to decided to try an alternative to lettersol.
So lettersol is a robotase inhibitor, which decreases all estergins in your body.
Because my bones were aching, my eyes were so red and dry and constant, eye drops did
not help.
So, when medications have a lot of side effects to them, and certainly the side effect
can be coming because it is a chemical that's affecting other things in your body, and
the side effect can be coming because it is doing what it's actually intended to do,
which lettersol has meant to drop all estergins down to an animal stuffing, and then you're
going to have side effects from not having an estrogen because you're supposed to have
estrogen.
Question goes on.
I have aromaclear, astroclear, and aloevia amude.
So the aloevia amude has nothing to do with lower estergins.
This is an immune-stimulate polysaccharide.
These two products, as well as, as I've ordered so far as I had, so these two products and
so far as I will help lower bad estergins.
Since I'm using them as an alternative, what is the recommended amount I should take?
The aromaclear typically I'd recommend two to three per day of these, and this also has
to do the, there's some caveats to these two.
It depends on, you know, if a person is in relative remission, then they can be unless, if
their cancer is growing, then they want to be on more.
And this is assuming that a person is either ER, PR, or HER2 positive.
If your ER negative, PR negative, and HER2 negative, what's called triple negative, still there
could be benefits to taking these products because, personally, I don't necessarily completely
trust their testing.
So the astral clear is a linkedin product that I would take again about two to three per
day.
And the so far as I am, is a broccoli product that's one of the clearest on the market.
This can be really effective, not just to lower estrogen levels, but it can actually be
a cancer killer and a hormone balancer as well.
And this one I would suggest at least for a day, probably, on this one, and you could go
lots of time that put people on higher doses of sub fours on.
And are there supplements that should never be taken again, no, you're not going to have
any issues with any of those, you could take all those together.